hold on just a moment
foreign
thank you
okay we're just about to get started
here
so I will put away the clock
and
recording in progress
going to welcome in our
LinkedIn live audience
got it
uh Welcome to our LinkedIn live audience
and well everyone who's here on Zoom
YouTube live or LinkedIn live
and I'm going to welcome you to the
career information session
on accelerating your data science career
with the postgraduate program from
Caltech ctme Center for technology and
management education my name is Stuart
Creek I work or simply learn we are the
delivery partner
with
Caltech ctme
so we provide the platform
and they provide the program oversight
and curriculum
and uh part IBM is also a partner in the
program so I'll describe that for you
and uh we'll be hearing a little bit
today from Mike Ash who is one of the
executives Caltech ctme
um
he has been in industry for quite a long
time
and he manages the new professional
education programs the Caltech CTE me
offers which we
are partners with about
I think 10 at this point so we're very
proud of that partnership and I'll talk
about that a bit but I'm also going to
have you hear from shubham Pandi one of
our senior trainers
he is going to take you through the
learning management system
how it works and what you can expect
from the experience in this program
so
we'll talk about data science careers
we'll talk about what this program
offers how the program gets you job
ready
I'll take you through the enrollment
steps and share with you a bonus offer
that you'll receive for being here today
on this webinar
and then we'll take your questions so if
you have questions uh that you'd like me
to take toward the end of the
presentation please put them in the Q
and A and zoom or put them in the
comments or chat box within your
streaming service and we will get to
those toward the end of the presentation
so remember to stay with us to hear
about the bonus offer
at this point I'm going to let you hear
from Mike about careers in data science
so
allow me to do
that
so let's talk a little bit about careers
and in data science so
you know
not only has this been
popular and everyone already knows that
but the amount of data that is out there
is is staggering I mean you can't even
really wrap your head around it
um 175 zettabytes uh is
more than I could imagine uh a lot of
that is a video a lot of that is an
unstructured text a lot of that is in
structured data and we all need ways of
understanding what that is what are the
patterns how do we use this whether
we're using it for science or we're
using it for business or other
applications
um it's a a huge field and maybe some of
you on this webinar today are looking at
changing your career to move into the
field
um if you're already a technologist and
you want to expand what you're doing and
we'll talk a little bit about how this
might be relevant for you
some of the many roles across data
science that this program is going to be
relevant for
um include people who want to be a data
scientist who want to be a better
analyst
architect information
um architect Technologies
um
applying machine learning and and
business intelligence and visualization
to commercial problems
uh perhaps you want to get into
statistics uh with a you know for
research or business
and just being an overall kind of
analytics engineering and that is more
than just the Technologies but it's the
communications it's being able to
understand what is this data telling us
what does it mean and and whether or not
we should act on it
and so these are many roles that are
available in almost any kind of company
and if you're pursuing these kinds of
roles there are a number of skills that
you need to excel in and one boot camp
is not going to give you everything you
can't be an expert just by finishing but
in a comprehensive program like ours
that you're going to cover many of these
things and you're going to know a
substantial
uh fortunate in order to land that job
or operate successfully in the role
right so it you already need to be kind
of clever and come in with an
understanding of math and and basic
statistics but what you're going to get
into here to build skills is more around
what is it what kind of data do we need
to solve problems how do I get that
how do I manipulate that data
um how do I get it ready to perform
certain analyzes
is it something that we can apply
machine learning to
how do we train that machine learning
how do we package all that together and
whether we're scripting or coding or
using python
we'll have to get into those things
um and so having that kind of broader
analytical thinking and critical
thinking you also need to bring
um
your skills and the scientific method
having a hypothesis finding the data and
and
solving those problems proven or
disproving those hypotheses
whether it's for business experiments or
research or other
we're going to work on
making you
a better analytical thinker
so here is where I'm going to ask you
your first poll question
on to
this first poll question
and what has stopped you up until now
from enrolling in a program like this
and becoming an expert in data science
getting certified in data science
so is it because you can't find a
program that has
the comprehensive curriculum that covers
all the skills that Mike talked about
is it because you don't have confidence
you'd end up with practical experience
that you could use to show off your new
skills is it because you find it
difficult to learn
the self-learning pre-recorded video
environment or is it because you can't
find the time in your schedule to do it
to answer all one two or all four of
these issues and if you're on the
streaming service you can use ABC or D
to
and in for the choices
I'm going to close the poll in about
five seconds
four three
two one
the biggest objection people have is
that they don't feel that they would
come out of a program with practical
experience to be able to show off their
skills and demonstrate that they've done
the work and know how to do it
um and the other bigger objections are
not having a curriculum that's fully
comprehensive and finding the time
within your schedule so
let's talk about
this program
a postgraduate program in data science
from Caltech Center for technology and
management
Nation
it is an 11 month
fully online program so you do it
completely online you do it from your
desktop or laptop anywhere you are
you can do it 24 7 the only requirement
that is scheduled is the live virtual
classes that happen on the weekends
where you spend four hours Saturday four
hours Sunday
interacting with your instructor in the
classroom environment online
you get to ask them questions they get
to ask you questions they take you
through live examples you interact with
your peers
and then between those weekend sessions
you have your Labs your projects
tell study videos to prepare for next
week's class that type of thing
all of that's available to you 24 7. you
can do it or do it on your own schedule
much of the materials accessible on your
mobile device so
you can actually watch the self-study
videos while you're commuting or doing
other things so
um very flexible you only need to devote
about 10 hours a week
over the 11 month period
and as I'll go through with you the
curriculum is very comprehensive it's
industry aligned Caltech ctme
the branch of Caltech that transfers
Knowledge from the University and the
research institutions into industry they
work very closely with companies and
other organizations to understand what
their employees need
to know about technology skills to have
in technology and they designed their
programs around those needs you also
notice that IBM is part of this program
and they add another dimension of
Industry alignment so
excuse me
pardon me
one moment
sorry about that um
and everything you do on the program is
done on the online environment including
integrated Labs including any support
you need you have a community
uh interact with your fellow classmates
and your instructors you can access 24x7
support not only for the platform itself
but also for the subject matter so if
you're working at three o'clock in the
morning on a project
an answer or some help
if some doubter blocker that you want to
get past you can
get help
anytime
so at the end of the process you'll
receive
several important benefits number one
you'll have the certificate from Caltech
which certifies that you've completed
the program successfully that you have
demonstrated the skills you taught in
the program that you've done your final
Capstone project
uh to show
employers what skills you have and how
you use them
uh you also receive certificates along
the way from IBM for the classes that
they provide within this program
integrated into the program and IBM
issues those certificates
um
you'll be doing more than 25 projects
along the way so you will build up a
portfolio
of
demonstrated experience that you can
show off
to not only your current employer but
future employers potential employers and
demonstrate how you have used each of
these skills extremely important
when you're facing interview questions
about how to use a particular tool or
take a particular approach use a
particular algorithm
along the way you can take master
classes from Caltech ctme instructors
and from IBM instructors
you have access to hackathons and ask me
anything sessions from IBM so you have
uh ability to add
a bit more to your experience
if you are in an industry that requires
you to provide continuing education
units
can demonstrate your continuing
education with 14 CEUs from Caltech ctme
into the program
these are
used by some especially in the U.S
official organizations to demonstrate
that you have taken continued education
to keep your skills sharp
that's an additional benefit and you
also get a membership in the online
Caltech ctme Circle
for industry networking with your peers
over time
you'll be invited to an online
convocation where they'll be recognized
by name
by the program Executives from Caltech
and simply learn
and you can invite your family and
friends to to see you
receive that honor so
we're as I mentioned before extremely
proud to be affiliated with Caltech
Caltech
is a private university not part of the
University of California or California
State University system
it's an institution that was founded
over 130 years ago
it focuses primarily on research it has
very few undergraduates compared to the
number of graduate students and
researchers scientists
doing work in the various research Labs
at Caltech and it is the home and alma
mater of a number of Nobel laureates
um many people earn Nobel prizes for the
work they did doing research at Caltech
and many people who earned Nobel prizes
for work they did elsewhere have come to
Caltech to continue their research the
home of many Advanced Labs including the
jet propulsion laboratory for NASA which
develops
deep space probes develops and builds
them so it's a very exciting
institution it's consistently ranked in
one of the top five universities in the
world
um if you have ever seen the television
program The Big Bang Theory
um
know that it's set at Caltech because
they wanted to pick a place where they
would find
the concentration of the smartest people
in the world so this is one of the
places where you can find a high density
extremely bright people
having Caltech on your resume therefore
is a
big accomplishment people will recognize
that so
move on to IBM and our affiliation with
them and we're also very proud of that
simply learn works with IBM in a number
of programs and in this case uh IBM
offers
a python for data science which is a
required course in this program it also
offers the elective R programming for
data science
and
as I said you have access to elective
ask me anything sessions hackathons
master classes you'll receive for the
courses that you do the IBM instructors
you'll receive IBM sort of certificates
so talk about the eligibility and
prerequisites
to join this program you must have a
bachelor's degree with 50 marks or
better this is a post a graduate program
so
um
do you have to have the bachelor's
degree you do have to have a basic
understanding of Concepts and
programming and math but you do not have
to have uh experience as a programmer
mathematician statistician you just have
to have
basically I've taken the courses in
college
University
or have other experience with
programming for example projects you've
done on your own
just so that you can demonstrate
the basic understanding
we say that you want to have two or more
years of work experience so you
understand how data is used in
organizational environments it is not a
hard and fast requirement so you can
come into this program without work
experience but again we do recommend
that you have that
um
at this point I'm going to ask another
poll question
this poll question is uh folks in the
audience how much experience do you have
informal work not necessarily in
technology work but in the workplace
while you answer that question and check
something else here
and I'll be with you in just a moment to
end the poll
and
one moment
okay
apologize for that delay
so more than half of our audience are
people who are currently studying
presumably that means you're in
University working on your bachelor's
degree
and you will have to wait until
a formal requirement is that you need to
have completed your bachelor's degree by
the time you complete this program so if
you are within
10 months say of getting your bachelor's
degree uh you're eligible uh on the
education basis to enter the program
um if you're further than that you'll
need to wait a little bit for the rest
of you who are have work experience
uh presumably have your bachelor's
degrees
uh
you're good to go so
let me move forward
we'll talk about how this program
prepares you and at this point I'm going
to let um let you hear from shubham
Pandi one of our senior instructors who
will take you through the learning
environment that includes managing your
curriculum what the live classroom looks
like tests and assessments Capstone
project
uh how to track your progress through
the system
and the support tools so
let me let you hear from shubham now
this is where I'm going to um
let shubham present to you the learning
environment the learning management
system
sure
thanks is Stewart
let me share my screen for that
and he'll give us a bit of a tour of
what the experience is like for learners
my screen is visible to all of you
yes it is
so this is uh
how your learning management system
would look like when you will log into
your LMS LMS when I say I mean learning
management system
so learning management system is
basically a One-Stop shop for you for
all your learning requirements
so I'll just take you through this
learning management system I need to I
guess refresh my page
here you go
so
uh here here I have these programs I
have enrolled for I'm a trainer so I'm
enrolled into multiple programs
so I'll go to one of these programs say
post graduate program in Ai and machine
learning I'll click here on this tab go
to program
so in this program we've got these all
courses course one welcome class for
Purdue AI machine learning program it is
for cardio so I just opened that that
was handy that was ready for me uh PGI
python for data science then you've got
data science with python machine
learning so all these courses are given
here
uh in a very structured manner so that
if you start from scratch even if you
don't know anything you can start from
scratch and then you can get to the Acme
of this particular Zone this particular
field
so if you'll click on any of these
courses
you will land into this page
okay
so this is a self-learning course
here you have these self-paced videos so
there are some there are some self
learning courses there are some
instructor driven courses the idea is to
give you the holistic learning
so I just opened the self learning now
I'll open the instructed let course so
here you have everything
so this is a course machine learning
so here you've got these self-paced
videos lesson wise in a very very
structured way
these are the self-paced videos so
before you go for the class before you
go for the live class you can prepare
yourself
you can get yourself ready with the uh
overview of that particular subject
that will give you an edge in the class
you'll be able to discuss better with
the
instructor
you can join your classes through live
class tab
uh okay
this is a practice lab this is a
cloud-based lab so you don't require to
install any tool you can work on
cloud-based environment so this is
an environment in which you will work in
real life as well so when you work in
this environment you get ready
for any corporate work to work in any
analytics team so the idea is to make
your industry ready so we make you work
in those environments where you make
yourself comfortable
and you work as if you're working in the
real life
uh project environment
then you've got assessment here here
you've got projects so many of you are
asking about the experience about the
application part so here we have the
projects
which are very close to real life
situations so you'll get to work on
these projects
and you will be evaluated on these
and once you will be done with the
project summation
and once you
qualify all the criterias you can unlock
your certificate
that's how it is
it does not end here here we also have
community
okay so on this community forum
you can interact uh with the students
with the batchmates and with your
faculty you can share your thoughts here
you can share your ideas here you can
ask your questions here
on this platform
files can be shared so this community is
also very useful for the learning
purpose
so this is all you have apart from that
you also have all the content in the
form of
PDF in the form of data sets because the
way of training is case study based so
we uh all the trainers that simply learn
we follow case study based approach of
training because we all know that it's
not about only learning mathematics it's
not only about learning programming
it's about how you apply
the learning into solving real life
problems right so we focus on
application part and that's why we
follow case study approach and we make
my our students work on different types
of projects from different Industries
so this is all about the LMS steward
great and I'm going to ask you to show
them a little bit later about the
Capstone project and and the importance
of that but then that's the
the final
part of the program that um all the
other courses lead up to and we'll talk
about that in a couple moments oh yes
that is very important so we'll talk
about that as well
okay thank you for that and if you saw
with that demonstration that was a
demonstration of how the platform works
the difference for you will be that it
will be the Caltech
uh curriculum for the data science
program which consists of
these core courses
and electives
so you start off with the program
with an induction session and the
induction session just gets you oriented
towards that how to use that LMS
what your curriculum will be what your
expectation is for attending the live
classes and how many of those you must
complete in order to earn your
certificate
um
how to prepare between classes with your
self-study videos and with your labs and
projects
and then you move into your first class
which is statistics Essentials for data
science the basic Foundation of data
science
is
um how data patterns
appear in what statistical methods can
be used to
identify those patterns and extract
information from them so that's your
foundational course then you move on
into python for data science again an
IBM course which
pairs you with
skills to do Python programming is the
next module after that is going to be
applied to data science with python and
using the Python language
in order to solve actual data science
problems
so you'll get training and experience in
that
then you'll move into machine learning
which is how
statistical models teach themselves
when they get more data so this is the
process
that underlies artificial intelligence
in most instances in this
process by which
data modeling improves itself in an
automated fashion so extremely important
move into Tableau which is how to
visualize data and present it to end
users who may not be data scientists but
who need to use the insights from the
data
and then you'll move into
your um
Capstone project which ties together all
of the things you've learned in the
previous courses into a project where
you're solving a industry-based
challenge
it's about a three to four week process
and I'll talk about that in a little bit
more detail later
along the way based on your level of
interest and your uh time availability
you can take any or all of the electives
you see down here on the right side so
you can take business analytics with
Excel
um SQL training you can do R programming
a power bi for the Microsoft
visualization
business intelligence tool
um deep learning with tensorflow
you want to get farther into machine
learning and AI
and you can take master classes with
Caltech instructors and with IBM
instructors which we also mentioned the
amas and
hackathons that IBM offers so all of
those are available to you they are at
no extra cost in the program just based
on
what interests you and what your
commitment of time you want to make
along the way you're going to be not
just exposed to but you're going to be
required to use a number of different
tools
um
some of these you'll have to use in the
core courses and some of them are from
the electives but when you are required
to use for example Python and libraries
numpy and scipy
it's not a matter of you'll be able to
say yes I know what the python scripting
language is and I know how it's used
you'll be able to show examples of how
you've used it in projects and solved
different data science problems so
that'll be part of your portfolio and
part of your ability to demonstrate your
skills later on so when you put it on
your resume you'll be able to back it up
that applies to all of these tools that
you will be using and applying so
uh that's a very powerful part of the
program
it gives you the ability to say with
confidence that you can show somebody
um your experience with these tools so
the Capstone project
we think is an extremely important part
of the process also because
it's the last formal class module it is
three to four weeks of
meeting with your instructor weekly to
go over the challenges
you build your project
individually so you choose a Capstone
Challenge from several different domains
and different business problems
and then you build a solution
um
the end of that process that project
gets created
how you
finally unlock your your
certificate for the entire program
um but it's also something that's part
of your
personal portfolio going forward so you
can show that to essential employers as
an example of how you took
a challenge from the ground up and
solved it completely built the solution
yourself
it's an extremely important part of the
program we also
um I want to point out that the program
director
Rick Hefner is the
senior director for all of Caltech ctme
and oversees this program and all the
other programs and
he has over 40 years of experience in
Industry academics and
research so
he brings a lot of expertise to the
program and he Mike and the
instructor staff the county Caltech ctme
um
oversee the program the curriculum and
make sure that it's being delivered
according to their standards
talk a little bit about learner outcomes
so from
industry
we take people coming in from different
companies who enroll in this program
as we mentioned
don't have to have work experience but
many people come in with work experience
and they come in from companies like
Amazon or Accenture or Bosch Automotive
um or Wells Fargo bank or Abbott
pharmaceutical so you you can see that
it's a wide spectrum of Industries
people that you'll be studying studying
alongside
that gives you opportunities for
networking with those people
um
we will talk about the career assist
service
that is available to you uh for students
in India if you are in other countries
we can't offer the career service as
part of the program yet all the other
benefits but this one is specifically
for
uh Learners in India what it offers
first off you do get wherever you are
access to our expert webinars and career
events so that's available to you
worldwide and those are free I'll talk
about those in a moment
um your
project portfolio as I've mentioned the
experience you gain in the portfolio in
the program to build your portfolio of
experience that's available to everyone
worldwide it's the job assist services
with IAM jobs that are specific to India
they start at the end of the boot camp
and continue for six months after end of
the EGP and continue for six months
um after that so this is part of
the service that helps you with your job
search it is not a job guarantee program
do not guarantee that you will find a
job after this but we guarantee that we
will provide you with the assistance
through IIM jobs to help you find a job
uh first part of that is their employer
Network and their exclusive job listings
so that you can apply discreetly and
confidentially to a wide number of jobs
that they offer which is a valuable
service we think the other parts are in
fact even more valuable resume rewrite
is important because
when you submit a resume or CV to a
company
it doesn't go to a human being first it
goes into an automated tracking system
and an AI bot will compare the content
of your resume to the job description
so your resume has to be formatted and
worded in a way that the AI bot
can make that determination can
recognize what skills are in it what
experiences in it make that comparison
to the
job description and filter you in rather
than filter you out so that's an
important aspect of it but then once
that process happens a resume does go to
a human being it'll go into their screen
or onto their desktop and they will have
to look at it see that it's attractive
that it has the qualities they're
looking for so a resume that can do both
of those things the the AI filtering
aspect and the human feel aspect that's
kind of an art form working with a
writer who can help you do that is a
important part of the service
similarly the one-on-one interview crap
you're going if you
go through the resume filter and someone
calls you to set up interviews you'll
have to go through several rounds of
interviews
you know you'll have phone screens that
happen with HR people you'll have
technical skills interviews that happen
with the people who will be supervising
your work don't want to know what skills
you have and see your proof of those
skills and then you'll have interviews
that talk about your personality you are
fit with the team you're fit with the
corporate culture your ability to be a
team player
so having the opportunity to practice
each of those types of interviews
one-on-one
a really valuable part of this so we're
very proud that this is part of what we
can offer you in this program again for
this particular part for India Learners
only
as I mentioned the expert webinars are
available to everyone worldwide which
simply learn
Ducks weekly we bring in experts from
India from
around the world not and just India but
all around the world experts who talk
about the state of the industry or they
talk about specific skills yeah
access a a mini lesson on a particular
topic
you may get advice on your career and
how to prepare for your next career move
or
how to find your next job so all of that
is
free on an ongoing basis and
helps you with your career
and then as we talked about here are
some examples of the kinds of projects
that you'll do in the program in user
Capstone challenges
Mobility as a service would be something
like uber
um or other ride sharing where uh
need to provide the
solution to their Fair prediction model
um
an automobile manufacturer having how to
optimize
manufacturing test times
or retail how to do
accurate sales forecasting
and looking at different factors how
they affect the
predicted sales patterns so these are
all challenges uh
one of these for a Capstone project
do the
build the solution yourself so this is
what you'll be able to show off to
Future employers
the next cohort to this program
starts on the first of March with an
induction session in the classes start
on the 11th of March
again four hours Saturdays four hour
Sundays is the live class schedule not
all of the courses have live classes but
plan as if they do
and be aware that you'll be committing
your weekends for quite a long period of
time if you miss a class you can catch
up on it with class recording but you do
have to for different courses it's a
requirement for how many classes you
must attend live so
um the cost of this program is one lock
ninety five thousand
which can be financed
as well as six thousand four hundred and
seventy three dollars a month or 73
rupees a month pardon me
um
and the bonus that I mentioned oops
before I go on to this question the
bonus I mentioned is that you will
receive for being here today a 15
percent
discount
uh off of these program fees if you
enroll from this uh webinar so if you
sign up for the March cohort and mention
that you attended this webinar we will
give you a 15 discount off of these fees
um
when my colleague Arjun
type that into the chat if you would
please I mentioned the 15 discount is
the bonus we talked about
and um
based on what you've heard are you
interested in enrolling in this program
so
let me ask that question
and we'll leave this open for about 20
more seconds
get your answers in please close the
poll in about
five seconds from now
all right
and approximately two-thirds of the
folks who responded said they are
interested
uh which is fantastic I'm very pleased
with that
so let me share with you how to get
enrolled
enrollment steps are very
straightforward
you email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net once you do that and
then
margin I think if you would put that
into the
um chat that would be great
um ask us at simplylearn.net you'll
contact one of our learning Consultants
that way they will send you the
application and you'll need to provide
proof of your bachelor's degree uh
you'll need to verify any work
experience that you want us to consider
and you may have to take a simple
assessment test uh to show that you have
that basic understanding of programming
and Mathematics
um this is all to make sure that
you have the background and the desire
to succeed in this program because it is
an investment of 11 months of time and
substantial Financial investment you're
going to want to um
we want to know that you're you're
committed to succeeding as much as you
want to know that we're committed to
your success
that point you'll receive an admission
offer
and you can get scheduled for the next
induction session and your
get ready to start your classes
so for those of you who have said that
you are interested
um I'd like to know how soon you would
like
get involved are you looking to start on
the March cohort or are you looking
maybe for the one right after that in
April or May
or are you looking further down the road
I'll leave this open for another
about 10 seconds
get your answers in please I'll close in
four three
two one
so more than half almost 60 percent of
our audience uh wants to get involved
either in March or maybe in April May
fantastic and you want to contact ask us
at simplylearn.net to get that process
started for those of you who are looking
uh further out please do contact us
again at that same email address ask us
at simplylearn.net
and
you'll be able to
um
ask any questions that you want
to get answered and we'll be able to be
in line be informed about future cohorts
of the program so
at this point we can take questions and
answers again if you've put them into
the Q a I'll be able to see them there
and if you are on our streaming services
hopefully
uh these have been moved over into a
place where I can see them
the Arjun has been
tracking that so allow me to pull up our
question sheet see if we have any okay
um
so in the Q a
what are the prerequisites sir I think
we've talked about the prerequisites you
do have to have
bachelor's degree with 50 marks or
better and then you do have to have
basic understanding of programming and
Mathematics
um work experience is preferred but not
required so
uh
we have a question from adarsh who is uh
bully a beginner in programming
um how can you learn programming in data
science uh so a dart a darsh
uh if you have no background at all in
programming mathematics statistics
simply learn offers
some
free self-study courses that can get you
some basic understanding of those fields
and get you prepared from that
perspective for this you do have to have
the bachelor's degree requirement that's
a separate thing we can't
we can't provide from our website but
that if you've got a Bachelor's degree
and you want to get some background
programming in mathematics prepare for
this program you can check our website
for some of our um Paul skill up courses
that will
give you some of the basic background
for that
um
who says I am going to be finishing my
bachelor's in another four months will I
be eligible for the program
I believe the answer to that is yes you
want to contact our learning Consultants
to make sure that that's the case
um
I'm
I'm pretty confident that you can start
the program as long as you are going to
complete your bachelor's before the end
of the
postgraduate program so again contact
our learning Consultants
verify that please
um
singer mask whether we award a PG
certificate in AR and ml for this
program apart from the data science
certificate that's a separate program
and uh we offer an AI and ml program
through
our affiliation with Caltech as well as
other programs with their affiliations
with other universities
so you can contact the um
learning Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net you can ask the question
about the differences between the
programs because you may want to choose
for example if your focus is on an AI
and ml you may want to choose that one
instead of this program in order to
focus on that directly there's a lot of
the data science preparation that goes
into that program as well so
again ask that question uh we have asked
do we get a certificate after this
webinar you can ask for one and glad to
provide you one is only a proof of
attendance that you came to this
informational session
um
their certificate for simply learn
and from Caltech
is it valued by International companies
the answer is yes the reason
we're affiliating with uh
major universities both in the United
States and in India and in Europe and
other regions is that
um these are institutions that have
international reputation so Caltech
certainly is recognized
worldwide is one of the Premier Higher
Education and Research institutions
and
um so having a certificate from Caltech
is something that people will recognize
internationally
um
Anonymous attendees the certificate
important to show that we learned a
programming language so that's not the
primary focus of this program
however you will get a certificate that
shows that you are certified
Python programming
uh you can earn a certificate in our
programming and having those
certificates which this program happened
to be issued by IBM
certainly valuable so that
can back up any claim that you make that
you understand how to program in Python
or r
ope the schedule of the program runs for
11 months it's starting March 11th and
runs
live classes on the weekends so ask our
learning Consultants about the complete
program schedule
what kind of demand do data analysts
have in the job market of the us the
answer to that is the demand is very
high
um you check uh
indeed.com or Glassdoor and look or
dice.com and look at um
job listings for data analysts and their
overviews of the different
job areas
see the kinds of salaries that are being
offered and the number of jobs that are
listed and there are many thousands of
job openings for data analysts with uh
pretty high salaries
um and the reason is as
Mike shared
amount of data that's flooding into the
world
is
tremendous especially since the pandemic
when companies moved into the digital
domain
to remote work and non-contact work in
online ordering suddenly
there's much more data available about
consumer Behavior about business and
business transactions and so companies
need a lot of help extracting the
understanding knowledge and information
from that sea of data so
uh
uh will the skilled data science and
could ask a great question will the
skilled data science help us to find
better use of existing data we have for
our organization
the answer to that is emphatically yes
understanding data science will allow
you to look at different sources of data
within your organization and
gain insights into how you can whole
predictions and
prescriptions for future changes out of
that data
here is an example from
U.S during the pandemic
fast food
chain called Wendy's
um
understood that they would have
fewer people going into the restaurants
to pick up food during the pandemic and
more people would be ordering through
the drive-through
so they developed
mobile app
which would allow you to place your
order before you went to the restaurant
and tell the person at the drive-through
window
I'm here to pick up the order for Stuart
and they would have your order ready and
give it to you this made for greater
efficiency
however what they realized was that this
also gave them data about ordering
patterns tied to individual consumers so
now they could say well this individual
likes to order
10-piece chicken nugget every time they
come
so maybe we can promote to them our
chicken sandwich
um
they can do a number of different things
analytically with that data it can say
this person likes to order at 1 pm
rather than 12 noon to get their lunch
so maybe we can time our promotions to
them
and send them a push message
that will remind them to order at 12 30
PM
um
this became a huge driver for new
business for the company so this is an
example
uh kind of a
just one example of how an organization
realized that data science could help
them
take existing data or new data streams
in their organization and create new
value
um
Singham who has 17 years of experience
in automotive and lean Six Sigma Master
black belt and as you know singam
the fundamental principles of lean Six
Sigma are based on statistical process
control which is all data
um so
one of the aspects of this program one
of the reasons why companies like Bosch
and the automotive industry
um
so interested in having people trained
in data science
because
um you want to go beyond looking at
the data that goes into statistical
process control as a matter a matter of
monitoring the process and the quality
deviations in the process you want to
start looking at what else is the data
telling you in terms of predictive
maintenance needs
terms of ways you could reorganize the
manufacturing process greater efficiency
so data science can help you a great
deal in the automotive business
um
AJ Doss the first cement master in
engineering um AJ again this is a
postgraduate program so whenever it is
you are scheduled to graduate with a
bachelor's degree you will need um
Orient your timing around that
um
bastia says I'm an electrical engineer
am I eligible to this program I don't
have programming knowledge but I have
better math knowledge was the answer to
that is yeah you are eligible if you
need yet some programming knowledge
some basic understanding of programming
Concepts
again we have
the courses through our skill up program
where you can for free take some basic
programming
training and get that background you
don't need a great deal of programming
knowledge to be able to enroll in this
program
uh
what about Purdue University Purdue
University is a separate partnership
that we have
um and we do a number of programs with
them including digital marketing
so you you have other interests outside
of data science you can take a look at
some of those
with Caltech we do cloud computing
data science data analytics
um
Ai and machine learning
blockchain number of different
technology Fields with caltex we have a
number of programs
that we do with Caltech
um
is the tendency to be taken at the end
of the session if you're assuming today
this is already being recorded by zooms
on a problem
uh
uh and
I'm going to take a look
all right
um
so I think that covers
all of the questions that we have so far
a couple more that just came in I am
from Life Sciences background I started
learning about databases well this
helped me
and understanding completing the program
and the answer to that is yes
and um
certainly in life sciences
statistics are indeed science or the
foundation of all uh statistical
analyzes
uh
if you're looking for example to work in
Pharmaceuticals everything that's done
in clinical trials is based on
statistical analysis of the results
uh to determine whether there's a
statistical validity to a claim that a
drug is effective or safe
so that's just one example of how this
applies in life sciences
um and again we talked about the last
question opportunities
for data analysis
I've already addressed that
and with that I'm going to conclude
q a
and we'll move on to the end of this
program as we're
at our 60 minutes
so I just want to ask one last question
for those of you who asked whether you
would receive a certificate or attending
tonight's session
here is your opportunity if you want to
receive a certificate for tonight's
session please answer yes here
and also answer yes here if you would
like us to reach out to you and help you
get enrolled in the program
oh
leave this open for just another 10
seconds it's a yes or no question
get your answers in
and
I'll close it in three
two one
share the results
it's a little more than half of the
audience are interested
having us reach out again we will send
you a proof of attendance for tonight
and also answer any questions you have
about the program
with that
I want to thank you I want to thank my
colleague Arjun for helping
keep track of what's going on in the
chat and
q a for us and I want to thank all of
you for being here this evening whether
you are here uh in the zoom session or
on one of our streaming services
um I want to remind you that if you
enroll you will be able to claim a 15
discount on the program fees
a lot of
remind you to tell the learning
consultant when you email us at ask us
at simplylearn.net
you want to use the QR code to go to our
website to the program page
with the Caltech ctme
postgraduate program in data science
I'll take you there
and we on behalf of Caltech and on
behalf of Simply learn I would like to
uh offer you all a
opportunity to welcome you into the
Caltech and simply learning community
and we hope to see you in our courses
uh thank you again for being here that
concludes our webinar for tonight
foreign